eine parteistrafe eine hochschwangere
frau ab wo gehst du bei der svww dazu
mein erschütternden bericht ich bin
sicher die zeit zurückerinnern als
baugebiet der vorsitzende der ard war
sie ist vorsitzende der hsg und bleibt
auch vorsitzende alfred beitrag wird am
nächsten freitag ausgestrahlt also von
daher wissen natürlich große frage sich
warum stimmung zur auszeit und damit gut
wir machen bevor sie zu wehren wollen
auch nicht partei positionen werden und
sie sollten auch noch beide alter
geweckt auf alten fahrerin apparat war
der vergleich passt platten ich bin
nicht so recht mit mit stützrädern gehe
davon aus dass wir auf diesem ohne
partner geeint hervorgehen werden
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
wie das leben ist wie sagen dass sie
diese ganzen demonstranten bezahlt
werden von irgendwelchen spd leuten ok
bekommt denn so einer demonstration spd
wenn er hier natürlich franken doch die
sache gelöst sie anfangs hätten es mit
bußgeld gegeben von 20 euro streikgeld
ich war bei berlin bei der demonstration
20 euro gesorgt so wo wir das damals
kümmert wenn man wenn man draußen liegen
die aktive demonstriert gibt 20 euro
braucht man ein sondern das werde ich
ihnen natürlich auch prominent sich auf
dem parteitag mitte hulk hogan
also ich kann nur deutsch sprechen sehr
gut deutsch
halperin man kennt sich für ihre catcher
vergangenheit wie sie sind ein tier
gewesen die leute auf die matte
geschickt und auf der anderen seite gibt
es natürlich noch das problem mit bernd
löcke
herne
zum video
hätte der mann als [ __ ] ich versteh
ich glaube das ist lustig oder
also fliegt ernst im zwar nicht ganz auf
dem plakat ja aber es schadet das nicht
da es aber in gedanken ist ja bei uns
gedanken sind auch bei ihm ampel schon
wieder nicht wir haben wir endlich über
wir müssen reden
er hat nur ganz gut jetzt will ich auch
nicht mehr so einfach wollte ich machen
sie es gut
eine schöne zeit mit ihnen außer betrieb
das war's als parteivorsitzender jetzt
geht's rein vielleicht ein letztes mal
auf dann kommt der nächste
[Applaus]